sur le papier la ville de la mode buvron
dort tranquillement à l'ombre de la
célèbre tarte tatin tatin comme ses deux
sœurs qui décidèrent d'utiliser des
pommes de leur verger déjà avancé et qui
inventèrent la célèbre recette on
démarre par du beurre du sucre les
pommes après on met la pâte là en ce
moment on a on a des pommes qui sont
vertes mais en général on essaie de
garder des des
pommes un peu plus tard bon ils sont un
petit peu flé mais par contre pour la
cuisson ils sont bien mieux sinon ça
rend énormément d'eau et on a des
problèmes on a des pommes qui sont en
purée au lieu d'être confite quoi et
parce que justement la tarte tatin est
mondialement connue le maire de la mode
beuverron a décidé d'en faire une
vitrine de sa ville une cité de 5000
habitants qui pèse entre guillemets 54
millions d'euros en activité touristique
notamment équestre d'où la création de
l'association des ambassadeurs la tarte
tatin c'est une image mondiale c'est du
patrimoine gastronomique reconnu au
patrimoine immatériel de l'Unesco donc
c'est c'est une une image de marque
fabuleuse et quand on quand on prononce
le mot la Modot devrond en tar ttin et
quand on prononce tartatatin on doit
entendre la mode beevron on a au travers
de ça bien sûr de pouvoir parler de
notre cité de et de notre de notre
Sologne de façon dynamique donc bien sûr
de faire venir tous les gens porter de
bonne volonté que ce soit économique
touristique ou historique c'est
important ils sont déjà une cinquantaine
d'ambassadeurs certains venus du betin
mondain les dirigeants des principales
sociétés côté au 440